- They have destroyed that masjid
and that is a wrong thing.
- Yeah.
- But do you know how many temples
in Kashmir have they burnt?
350 temples.
- Are we settling scores?
- No.
- Exactly.
- Hindus and Muslims
are like the Montagues
and Capulets of India.
We've been waring for centuries.
(upbeat music)
- [Interviewer] Growing Up,
I was taught to stay
away from the other side.
Can the agreers please step forward?
- It wasn't said so strongly,
(both chuckle)
nothing really did.
There was generally a non-appreciation
of me hanging out with Hindu friends.
So there was not a clear thing
that don't hang out with Hindus,
but discouraging.
Where are you going?
He's a Hindu.
You don't even know how
they would have coped.
Why are you going to their
birthday party or something?
Whereas if I have a Muslim friend,
he was somewhat more welcome.
- So yeah, in my family
I think I have actually seen my parents
neglect a lot of my Muslim friends
and very sternly my mother
specifically walk up to me
and tell me that don't make Muslim friends
or whenever there was a
Muslim friend's birthday party
she would tell me not to go there.
So there was this very cold environment.
Like I would see my mother
not treating them very well,
not sitting with them
or trying to even initiate a discussion.
It really needs to be stopped.
You can't let your kids grow
in such a venomous environment
that it ultimately takes a toll on them.
And when they grow up,
they start just hating the other
community to such an extent
that they can't even engage
in discussions with them.
- [Interviewer] Can we have
the disagreers come forward?
(footsteps thudding)
- My experience was quite the opposite.
In my house, actually my
sister's best friend was Muslim
and she used to live in our colony.
And for every Diwali,
it's like she didn't have
anywhere to go or anything to do.
So she used to spend Diwali with us.
So my family's been very accepting.
- So for my parents, it was never a choice
because most of my
friends were Muslims only-
- Same.
- So there was no choice for
them to stop me somewhere.
But yes, it was communicated (indistinct),
never marry outside your...
- What I really enjoy whenever someone
from a different religion
would come to the house,
then the level of curiosity
that my parents would have.
- Absolutely.
(all chuckle)
- And that's also something
very bad about our society.
After 1000 years of coexistence,
there is still curiosity.
How dumb are we?
- [All] Yeah.
- Like you still don't know
about the other person.
(suspense music)
- I've been married to a Muslim boy
by my own will and choice,
of course, against my parents will.
They still don't speak
to my husband at all.
They have cordial relations with me,
which I think I've over the time
come to accept that it's okay
if they don't want to talk to him,
it's their decision at the end of the day
and I need to respect it.
- [Interviewer] Someone I know has died
because of this conflict.
(footstep thudding)
- We being Kashmir Pandits,
are treated as a minority
community in Jammu and Kashmir.
And because of this religious extremism,
my father was assassinated
when I was at the age of 15 or 16.
All house was coordinated by militants.
And he was taken from that my place.
And he was assassinated.
Because of this religious conflict,
certain innocents are being targeted.
And if the extremism and
conflicts will go on,
such things will happen.
(footsteps thudding)
- I think a lot of us (chuckles),
- Yeah.
- Are just tongue-tied
for now.
But if I may,
I think I just have had
a lot of respect for you,
like right now
because I think it takes a lot
to be a firsthand victim of a crime
and then still not develop that hatred
and let that hatred get so much to you
that you start blaming an
entire community for it.
Because at the end you have
to realize that an individual
or few individuals
belonging to that community
were actually responsible for it
and not the entire community.
So I think if we actually
had people like you
who were so practical and understanding,
we wouldn't be in this
situation we are in today.
- No, that's actually very true.
I've spent a lot of time
in Jammu and Kashmir.
My father was in the army,
we were posted there for a long time.
I've seen a lot of terrorism
and a lot of violence in front of me.
We didn't go to school for
many months because of that
so I've lost out big
chunks of my childhood.
Initially, when you'd introduce yourself
and you said you were a Kashmir Pandit,
I was immediately filled with fear
because I've had a lot of negativity
from people who tend to
harbor hate against people
with literally just my
surname, for of course,
things that have happened
terrible in their lives.
- [Pallavi] Yeah, absolutely.
- But to see somebody
emerge from such a situation
and then still come out the other side
with the level of maturity
that you are able to show right now,
it's really incredible to see yeah.
- What you have been through,
given that despite that personal tragedy,
you have managed to keep
yourself just and fair,
my salute to you.
And if it matters, I doubt it does,
but as a part of a Muslim community,
I am terribly sorry for your loss.
- See, that's the problem.
I mean, you can be sorry to him.
Why do you have to take the blame for it?
- [Both] Exactly.
- That is something
that I don't understand.
None of my business, not my problem.
Some people did it,
I am the representative for myself.
That doesn't make me absolute,
in the sense to represent
that entire culture.
It's just a tiny facet.
- It does.
- No. You know actually-
- Why.
- When you start being apologetic
for the entire community
is actually when you start
giving the other side
the chance to blame the entire community.
- Pallavi, made a point.
So she said that if
everybody was like him,
we wouldn't be here at all.
But I wanna just take to the other side
because to go what he has gone through,
I believe the pain would be immense.
And if that means that
I lash out at society
and the perpetrators, at whoever
or whatever was responsible
I believe that there is
hope for understanding
those kind of violent actions.
- Oh, absolutely not.
I so disagree with that point of view.
We'd be living in an
uncivilized and lawless society
if we actually start
propagating thoughts like this,
that being violent is okay at a point.
Your aggression, your being
upset at the situation,
the immense pain that you have felt,
I'm sure people are going to understand.
But saying that it's justified
for me to be violent-
- I'm not saying it's justified-
- I think that's wrong.
- If I understand what he's trying to say,
is if he goes out
because his family was
subjected to violence
and he killed somebody,
what he's saying actually
that killing somebody is bad,
that is not a justification for killing.
But probably what he's saying
is that when it comes to punishing him,
- Yeah.
- The history which existed.
So that should serve as not
a defense against his crime,
but a mitigating circumstance.
- [Pallavi] No, but
then I have a question-
- This guy understands me so well.
(Zarah laughs)
- How's that gonna change anything?
- [Pallavi] Exactly.
- I think that's the middle ground.
- Then how does that make him different
from the people who
assassinated his father?
How does that make him different then?
- See, what Pallavi is saying is that-
- Because he also went
ahead and shot those people.
Those people shot his father.
- Blaming an entire community
is not an answer to that.
- So where is the difference?
- We can justify by
doing through individuals
but blaming up complete
community is not justified,
so that is what Pallavi,
and I also agree on that.
Muslims and Hindus can bridge those gaps
because there are some negative energies
which will pull you in your way,
but we need to be tolerant.
We need to be very much patient
about the actions which we are doing.
- [Interviewer] The government
has created more divide
between Hindus and Muslims.
- Yeah.
- Really? Are you guys not coming forward?
- So I think of course you
have reports after reports.
In fact there is a New York Times post
that has clearly said and I quote,
" that the data of hate crime in India
gets released based on who the hater is."
So when the government of India
decides to release a data
on hate crimes in India
and it excludes lynchings of minorities
and only puts forward certain facts
where the majority is favored,
crimes against majority.
I think of course the government
has a huge agenda to solve
in pleasing the majority.
- If there would have been a
time angled to this problem
that would have made it much
more simpler for all of us
because I feel post independence,
all the governments in this country
have actually done nothing
good for the majority
and for the minority.
On a way, social sense
or economic indicators
we are not counting in,
the governments have definitely done,
that's why we are where we are right now.
- Make no mistake,
government since 1950s
wouldn't have done anything.
I agree with you.
But 2014 onwards, we have a government
who has an official policy to
discriminate against Muslims.
We have this Qurbani, the
sacrifice of the animal
and it takes place at our village.
And we go to village
and bring back the meat.
From last two years, we are
not bringing back the meat
because we believe traveling with the meat
is very dangerous.
They'll stop you and they'll
lynch you saying that it's cow.
So this government has multiplied hate
and hate crimes exponentially.
It is not something
which is just happening
and they're hypothetic about it,
this is their policy.
And these are seasoned politicians
making very absurd claims.
That you should go to Pakistan and all,
and you and I may think that
they're buffoons and idiots
but what they're doing actually
is they're normalizing it.
- Yeah.
- Unlike Congress and
which this politician
has said it very right,
Congress may be corrupt.
I agree with you, but this government
has overtaken the
institutions so completely.
The judiciary, the investigating agencies,
- [Both] The media.
- Yeah.
- So I think-
- All of that was already taken over on-
- No.
- Not so much.
- I think that's living incomplete denial.
Governments before this
must have done this.
What we are seeing now is a
support towards all of this.
- So basically you were-
- They supported
blatantly, it's happening,
without any regret that they're
violating the constitution.
- So the problem is the degree here-
- They're violating law.
There's open support for it.
When did we see previous
government supporting it?
They at least had the knack and the shame
to the go ahead and oppose it.
Even on the face open.
Even though you know in your head
there must have been some
way had a hand in this
but they never supported it openly.
What we see now is open
blatant, shameless support.
And it has led to such violent
situation on the ground.
Like he correctly said,
people are being lynched
for just carrying meat.
- I don't think it's the
government who did the lynchings
and the people who did the lynchings
they have been arrested.
And even our prime minister
has said several times
that it has denounced those acts.
So I don't think it's the
government who's not doing,
it's a law and order issue in UP.
And it should be looked at as that.
Secondly, I don't think the government
is increasing the divide
between Hindus and Muslims.
I think the divide has always been there
since the partition.
Second of all,
- No.
- Speaking to the Ram Mandir issue,
there my stance is the Muslims have
thousands of mosques all over the world,
but Ram was born only at one place.
So I personally believe,
that the Ram Mandir should have been there
and the the Supreme court
has given Islamic society
the right to build a mosque, right beside,
and it would be like why
would we ever want to take
kardha away from you?
It's like that.
That place is too special
to us than it is to you.
And just out of magnanimity,
it would be magnanimous of
the Muslims to just give that.
But I'm not really
emotional about that issue.
It could have gone either way
and I would've been fine with it.
- What you're saying is that the Muslims
should have shown magnanimity,
is what the general view would have been.
And the Supreme court has gone by it,
just because they're minority,
they're weak, they're less in number,
let them come forward and show magnanimity
and to the majority why
should we show magnanimity?
And let's not forget,
that a mosque did exist at that place
that was demolished.
There is proper videographic evidence
to show that people
were on top of the tomb
and they demolished that mosque.
And then you say, give it to us,
give the place to us
because Ram was born here.
And let me get
your facts right.
- And no evidence of that.
- There has been affidavit
in the Supreme court
by the government itself
stating that there is
no evidence whatsoever.
In fact, by the Archeological
Society of India,
also that there is no fact whatsoever
to state and to confirm that Lord Ram
was actually born at that place.
So your basic foundation
of why the judgment is good
is flawed in itself.
- So I just never wanted to go
on this mandir-masjid kind of a thing,
but I just want to clarify here,
maybe anybody who has done on masjid
they have destroyed that masjid
and that is the wrong thing.
But do you know how
many temples in Kashmir
have they burnt, 350 temples?
- Are we settling scores?
- Exactly.
That doesn't justify.
- So we should not,
this is a wrong thing.
- One wrong does not justify
the other.
- This is a wrong thing,
wrong statement to say-
- But you're justifying it.
No, so-
- That intolerance has
been to Muslims only.
- I was at work and the entire debate
about CAA and NRC was going on
and working in news means
that's a very big discussion topic.
If I was to ever voice an opinion
the immediate rebuttal
it's often said in jest,
but that doesn't of course make it okay.
Is, oh, why are you bothered?
You can just go back to Pakistan.
Even though I have
absolutely no affiliation
but my identity is then
brought into question.
My loyalty towards my country
is brought into question by these things.
It goes back all the way
to middle school as well.
- [Interviewer] Hindus and Muslims
can coexist peacefully in India.
- Really?
- Oh my God.
(Pallavi chuckles)
- Oh God,
it's just me.
- What is wrong
with you people?
Of course.
You are not born biggit.
You were turned into one,
by all these politicians
and all the men who wants to
keep their power to themselves
and don't want to work.
So they need things to divide people.
- I think we've been
living fairly peaceful
to be very honest.
There have been some incidences,
there is obviously been a spike,
but look at us.
We are having such a sound conversation
and there has definitely
been an increament
in the number of interreligious marriages,
more Muslim scholars being
part of public institutions.
I'm a thorough optimist.
I feel that the trajectory
is definitely going uphill
despite all the hiccups that we are facing
at this point in time
for political reasons.
- No, I don't agree
that it's going uphill.
I think it's getting worse as of now,
since 2014 like Kabir said.
But I think, yes,
there's definitely a place to coexist
because we have been doing that since,
even before independence
- A thousand years.
- So we have coexisted for so long.
Also I think the situation on the ground,
like we are all the privileged
lot, so let's accept that.
But even if you see very common
people on the ground also,
I don't think there is as much as divide
as being portrayed by the media.
And the only reason the
media is portraying it
is because the government
to its own benefit
wants to push this narrative
that there is a Hindu-Muslim divide.
That Muslims have been
the cause of your trouble.
They were the one whose
needs were always put forth.
And despite being majority,
you were always neglected.
So now we are going to look after you.
So I think the media's
just running that narrative
full throttle since 2014.
And it's just becoming
venomous, like Kabir said
fascism gets to you very, very slowly.
- I'm not very much comfortable
when you are saying after
2014 it had happened.
So I don't agree.
- Sure, it's all open.
- I don't agree with you on that thing.
Muslims and Hindus, if born in India
can coexist very peacefully
and only we need to leave our extremism.
So whatever maybe that Hindu extremism
or the Muslim extremism.
Extremism is the main issue,
which should be left behind
- You better defend yourselves.
(Pallavi chuckles)
- I think like you said,
it's a very optimistic view.
It's very idealistic.
I want it to happen.
I don't know if that'll happen.
You're right,
we have existed together
for a very long time.
We're barely existing together right now.
When this is not a symbiotic relationship,
we're not happy together,
I personally blame it on the old guard.
I think a lot of people have prejudice
because of the experiences they've had.
And that's trickling down
to younger generations,
perhaps not to make it
sound extremely dark,
but if that generations die out
and conversations like these continue,
there could be change.
But again, keeping our privilege in mind,
these conversations are
just how happening here.
I am super afraid of
having these conversations
outside of this.
I am afraid of backlash.
I am afraid of being othered.
I am afraid of being told that,
oh, you know, just go back to Pakistan
where you belong then,
you'll be comfortable there.
So I don't know if it's happening outside
of these sort of-
- It is.
In every educated household-
- Education is very limited though.
Again-
- It's not that limited.
Definitely, it's one of the
points that we have to focus on.
- I wanted to make the point out
that why is encourageable
optimism is not misplaced.
Things are bad right now, of course.
And is there fight
between Muslim and Hindus
which weren't there earlier?
Say Muslims came to India say 1000 AD.
Were there wars before that?
- Of course, yes.
- Were their Muslims,
when there was Mahabharat?
Was their discrimination
before Muslims came?
There was a cast system.
There is nothing particular
about any one particular community.
So Hindus and Muslims are not that,
unique pair who can never be together.
Majority of us agree that
they can live together.
All of us want them to live.
- Absolutely.
- Only difference would be
like, you know how much?
So I think we should be optimistic.
I implore all of you.
We certainly can live together.
- Oh, you just put our foot here.
- I will, standing.
(indistinct)
(all exclaiming)
- Making coexist.
(all chuckling)
(upbeat music)